okay hi I'm Jonah I think this is my
third time speaking at one at one of
these meetups at least thank you for
having me back
so I my primary job is to work on Stan
or Stan related stuff at Columbia
University for I assume most people here
have heard of Stan if you came to hear
me talk but for anyone who hasn't it's a
programming language instead of
algorithms for writing statistical
models primarily Bayesian models
although not necessarily but until I
don't know a couple years ago to work
with Stan you really had to learn and we
still prefer that you do but you really
had to learn the Stan language and
really and it's been a barrier to entry
I think for a lot of people there's a
lot of programming languages out there
people get familiar with our or Python
and then you have other things taking up
your time and so learning a new language
and especially one that's related to
subtleties and statistical modeling can
be challenging so we've tried to start
developing packages and they've been
going for a couple years now on these
four are and hopefully Python at some
point but there's some other people
working on that hopefully a Julia at
some point but right now in our for
fitting models using stand at the back
as the backend but letting you use
familiar native like are modeling syntax
to fit those models and there's a couple
different ways to do that don't mention
today but more like beyond that even if
you're working with stan yourself and
not using one of these packages if
you're using our stand so you write a
stand program and then yourself and then
fit the model and get results in our
we're also working on on tools to
basically give you recommendations and
routines that we find work really well
in a Bayesian applied Bayesian workflow
and this is ice I'll mention at certain
points in this talk but this is work
that's being done by a lot of people not
just me I see few in the room right now
who I'll mention at some point when I
get to their stuff but there's like a
whole large team at Columbia working on
this and then people from all around the
world are contributing also and so if
you're someone who's interested in
Bayesian modeling and you know R and you
want to contribute definitely let us
know that would be great okay so the
first thing I'm going to do is actually
not talk about our I'm just gonna tell
you what's going on outside of our
briefly because actually but then I'll
relate it back to our there's a lot of
work being done in Julia both by Brian
who you heard talk about the job a
second ago and Rob Goodman we are
Mitsy who's here is working on some new
stuff for Python more lightweight
interfaces for Python there's a new HTTP
interface to Stan I'll share these
slides afterwards these some of these
are like hyperlinked to the actual sites
there's HTTP interface systems developed
by Allen riddle there's some stuff
that's similar to things that we've been
doing in our with the base plot package
that are available in a new Python
library called RV's that has been done
by some people that we collaborate with
and some others and then finally I guess
the last one does touch on our but we
want to make the interfaces to stand
more similar to each other to have less
differences in user experiences if
you're using Stan from our Python or
Julia or something like that so this is
stuff that's mostly going on outside of
our and of course this doesn't cover the
actual development going on in terms of
new stuff in the Stan language there's a
new compiler being written and all that
stuff these are more like interface
things that are that are happening but
so there is stuff going on outside of
our but by far the most work that's been
done has been an AR and that's partially
just because some of us who have been
real
involved with Stan are also our users
and so we've you know first started
implementing stuff in our and we've
slowly gotten more people involved from
other other languages like Python and
Julia and so that's unfortunate well I
don't think maybe maybe I should not do
it fullscreen
yeah well that's not gonna work either
okay so you're gonna have to part in the
the line that's in the middle of this
slide I'll explain it in a second this
is a not entirely coherent partial map
of what I'm calling the Stan ecosystem
in our and then there's there's a
extensions to this which I'll talk about
in a second
this is contained to just stuff that's
being done by the Stan development team
but there are a lot of other people
contributing too and there's other
packages that I'll mention also but
basically what happens is this we this
err this big arrow up here if you can
kind of see is like Stan Wright the C++
code everything that goes on there and
we have this package called Stan headers
which you basically never need to
interact with yourself but it a lot but
it's like the foundation of our Stan and
all these other packages which basically
contains the stand
C++ headers and so then there's our stem
which is the main our interface to Sam
so if you write your own Stan program
right in the Stan language you can fit
it from an our session using our Stan
and with your data and as our various
types of our objects however to use our
Stan you need to know how to write in
the Stan language which is great but
there's definitely I mean there are
whole there's a whole Ben Goodrich one
of the other Stan developers teaches a
whole semester course at Columbia and on
Bayesian statistics and Stan you can
only really get into like learning the
Stan language towards the end of that
class and even then you don't become an
expert so it's a lot of it's a lot of
work to learn a new programming language
to learn an R and so this next level of
tools
is hopefully a way for people to start
using these tools before your
necessarily an expert at this level our
Stan arm and BRMS are to our packages
that have Stan programs that well in our
stein arms in case are already written
and precompiled and in BRMS this case
get written for you as you interact with
the package I'm gonna talk about I'm
gonna show an example using our stand
arm today I'll talk a little bit about
the differences between the two but the
main difference is that our Stan arm you
don't have to deal with C++ compilers at
all the models come out of the box
precompiled and a lot of the headache
for new users of Stan and experienced
users of Stan is dealing with the C++
tool chains and stuff like that so our
Stan arm gets around that entirely
models are pre compiled ahead of time B
RMS writes models on the fly for you
which lets it fit a wider range of
models than our stand arm but you have
to deal with the C++ tool chain anyway
so these are packages and we'll see it
where you specify our regular arm
modelling syntax like you would with
like the GLM function or something like
that
and it'll get the model will get fit and
Stan and you will get posterior
distributions instead of point estimates
or whatever some of these other packages
are giving you and so you might say this
our Stan tools package which I'll
actually let me hold off on that one
this next row here are what I'm calling
like post-processing tools although
that's pretty vague they're all quite
different so this says shiny Stan I'm
sorry about the paneling here this says
shiny Stan which is a shiny app
basically so people I know people are
familiar with our Studios shiny web
framework which is really cool and it's
a shiny app that essentially takes a
fitted model either from our Stan are
one of these packages and brings up a
bunt like a GUI graphical user interface
where you can look
plots and diagnostics and summary
statistics Bayes plot here is somewhat
like a static version of shiny stands
it's just creates ggplot objects for you
but and none of the coding necessarily
behind Bayes plot is revolutionary at
all but it is basically there with a
full like library of functions that we
think are useful at different stages of
the analysis so you don't have to write
your own code to check important
Diagnostics to look at just posterior
distributions for certain types of
parameters if you want to do more
customized stuff I'll talk in a minute
about some packages that other people
have contributed that will do that
here this says loo like toilet in the UK
and that stands for leave one out which
is a package for doing basically
efficient approximations to leave one
out cross validation for like full
Bayesian models right so not dealing
with point estimates and solu is used to
say you fit a model with our Stan you
fit a model with one of these
higher-level interfaces and you want to
compare it to another model or several
other models on estimated out-of-sample
predictive performance so you can use
the loop package for that and it's
designed to work with like posterior
distribution right so not models that
just return point estimates but that
return you know some large number of
samples from a distribution and then
this proj
again sorry it looks like it's crossed
out
it stands for project projection
predictive variable selection or maybe
it's around which is a package that does
a variable selection which has been
developed by some of our colleagues in
Finland and so if you fit a model with a
lot of covariance and you're interested
in like you know can I find a smaller
subset of these that are sufficient to
attain the same predictive accuracy or
something like that you can use the prod
prod package and again all these
packages
designed to link up with each other and
accept the output from one package into
another or some small transformation of
that output into the next layer and I'll
show examples of this in a moment these
arrows loosely tell you which of these
packages kind of work with the others so
for example if you do cross-validation
and LU then the base plot package has
some nice diagnostic plots for that the
prod pred package relies on some of the
internals in the liu package to do some
of the calculations for the variable
selection so these are all kind of tied
together here stop by the way feel free
to interrupt me with questions at any
moment you have that de stud carry also
you have people who used these packages
at all our center arm and BRMS a couple
okay cool so that really is new
information for a lot of people okay so
I'm going to show you these in a second
before I do so this is this these are
the packages that our developers that
are part of the stand development team
are working on and we started working on
this other package called our stand
tools which basically tries to take
stuff in our that's being done by both
of these packages and avoid code
duplication basically like and avoid
conflicts in naming of methods right so
it has a bunch of generic functions and
then these packages define methods for
them but it also allows us to provide
like a template essentially for how do
you create your own our package that
fits stand models right and we have a
new release of arson tools coming out
soon that's going to make this process
even easier but basically what it'll do
is it'll set up the package directory
structure for you so that you can
appreciate every and then fit it and
stand and return whatever you want to
your users and so
actually I realize now that this
rethinking package is one of these that
doesn't use our stand tools but there's
a lot of them you can see them on cran
but there so there's a lot of other our
packages that are coming out now that
either explicitly tell you or if you
look into it you'll find that in the
back end they're fitting models and Stan
if you look at the our stand package pay
again actually all of these are
hyperlinked too so I'll share these
slides you can click on each of these
names and I'll take you to a webpage for
each of the packages but so was I saying
yeah if you go look at the cran page for
our Stan you'll see all the packages
that depend on it now and most of them
are like now model fitting packages like
particular models that instead of
everybody who wants to fit that model
has to rewrite it themselves somebody
puts together the stand program for that
and then allows you to input your data
from our and can release it as an our
package and then finally there's the
relatively new package called tidy bays
which is very cool which if for example
you want to make more intricate
customizable plots or something than the
ones that Bay's plot gives you you can
use tidy base to basically manipulate
data but in this case the data are like
posterior drawers and put them in Nice
data frames for ggplot and other things
in the tidy verse and so tidy bays and
some of these other packages which I'll
mention are not being developed by the
stand development team but play really
nicely with the Stan ecosystem and we
think are really cool tools but if let
me show you for a second
I'm just going to click on here
oops
so this is what you'd get if you know
sorry I meant to show you the our stamp
page right so this is the I'm sure many
of you have seen these web pages before
the cran project page for our Stan and
all of these packages here most of them
now are fitting models and not all of
them but most of them are fitting models
matter if it's if the Markov chains have
converged but but yeah so the rows here
are like drawers and the columns are
like observations right and so this plot
is summarizing this the thick curve is
like a kernel density estimate of the
observed data and each of these thin
blue thin curves is a kernel decimate
and kernel density estimate of one of
the rows of this matrix here all right
and so what is this saying this is
saying well how well what's the
uncertainty and how well do our
predictions for this data match the
observed data of course if we match it
in every tiny little facet and although
no it capturing the noise we might over
fit but we certainly want to be
plausibly fitting the data right and so
this doesn't tell you necessarily so
that and also this is looking at the
whole distribution of the outcome like
the marginal distribution of the outcome
we can also make these plots like by
group by we can compute summaries I'm
going to show you an example of that in
a second
anyway this is this is the call to make
this plot from our stand arm and
basically under the hood this is what
it's doing in the Bayes plot package so
this this PP check function calls
posterior predict and then passes it to
the appropriate function this is from
Bayes plot here and there's like tons of
these functions for all sorts of
different scenarios that you might find
yourself in right and so another example
this top line here is again equivalent
to this in Bayes plot here what this
does is might look a little smushed here
right I'm making let me put a label on
the x-axis to me
oops why is valence
so this is actually a plot with the X
variable on the x-axis so arousal on the
x-axis and the outcome on the y-axis and
these are 90% so the 50% and 90%
predictive intervals right and then
these are the observed data points
eyeballing it right now it roughly looks
like maybe 10% are outside the 90
percent interval which is good but we
could calculate that exactly but so we
have an interval here for each of the
observed data points again we could make
these for like out-of-sample predictions
too but so this is comparing each
observed data point to the predictive
distribution for that data point in
other words to a column of that previous
matrix if that makes sense and again we
can make the same plot directly using
the functions in the base plot package
which means that even if you're not
using Stan if you're doing any other
sort of MCMC or Bayesian simulations you
can also use the base plot package there
are some other packages writing their
own samplers that are still using base
plot it doesn't need to know about Stan
right and so there's a lot more
different plots in this package and each
one of them can be made using some
function in our Stan arm same thing for
the BRMS package and others that we'll
call those functions for you and prepare
the the data for them I'm gonna skip
this plot here so get a little more
interesting right are people familiar
with the LME are the Elmer function some
people I did some consulting with once
called it lemur which I thought was nice
right and so here we can just fit the
same model but now will allow for
different intercepts and slopes by this
is the like participant ID variable so
it's I know it's some coding
which the participant it is and so if we
fit that model we get some output that
looks somewhat like the output from the
LME for package like down here right
where to be totally honest like this
doesn't really make much sense from a
Bayesian perspective that these aren't
actually error terms
these are error terms and a frequent
frequentist statistics they're not
invincible we have kind of matches what
the LME for package is doing just so
that it's easy to transition right so
you get a summary of like the standard
deviation of the group level
coefficients and the correlation between
the slopes and the intercept
but unlike LME for package right we have
so we have full posterior distributions
for every one of the unknown quantities
including the covariance matrix but of
the so-called random effects although
and I really like that term right and so
for example let's look we can make other
types of plots now because we have like
grouping by participant so here's and
again all of these things are kind of
automated for you by using these
functions from our Stan are that make
the that call this phase plot package
for you so what's that this is a his 1
histogram per sorry that's this line of
them can't really see them both at the
same time this is one histogram per
participant where the vertical line is
like the median prediction for there
sorry the median observed value for that
participant there were multiple
observations per participant and then
this is the pristine the predicted
distribution of that me
right so now we're talking about
distributions of Statistics here not
just distributions of predictions right
so in other words that matrix that had
like one column per data point and one
row per simulation right I can now take
you know find all the columns
corresponding to participant five right
all the predicted data points for
participant five and I can compute the
median of those except I'm computing
that for like a hundred or thousands of
rows and so I'm going to get a
distribution so this is tell me what's
my uncertainty in predicting like the
median here right or whatever you can so
what's nice about this is it just
accepts a either a string or an actual
function definition here so anything
that takes a vector and returns a scalar
you can pass into here and so there'll
be different functions that are
appropriate to check for different
models if you are fitting some like zero
inflated model you might want to check
the predict the statistic might be a
function that calculates the proportion
of zeros in the data right and then
you'd get you know a plot like this
that's saying well what's the predicted
proportion of zeros for like this
participant or something like that and
does the model do a reasonable job
capturing what was actually observed for
them so it makes sense and so again
there's a way to do that directly in
Bayes plot here and like I was saying
this this could have this could have
been this just to demonstrate that this
could you know this could get more
complicated in here it just needs to
return a scalar and so it can be
whatever is like useful and your
analysis and so really the point here is
not that you should make these exact
plots that I'm making but that there are
tools to allow you to make the ones that
are appropriate for what you're studying
so like this plot checking the median by
participant might not make any sense for
what you're doing but you can check
other things the idea is to be checking
visualizations like
which I find are much easier to
interpret then like a numerical summary
of this I'm not sure if there would be a
good non painful way to sit and look at
the numbers underlying this plot right
and so are there how long do I have
Jared okay I wanted to show one last
thing so a one really nice thing
okay I'm gonna skip this but it's
compatible with the broom package for
like tidy summaries and stuff like that
but a nice thing about getting a
posterior distribution right instead of
just a point estimate here this we can
do something like this
so what is this plot so again these are
all the participants the gray points are
like the actual data so it's basically
the same plot that I showed out all the
way at the beginning like here's the
data right and then we have this dashed
line is like the populate like the
estimated like posterior mean regression
line right like just as in not
participant specific just the like
global regression line all right
and then these blue the dark blue line
are the mean the posterior mean
regression line for each participant in
other words each participant is going to
have like a different slope a different
intercept right we're gonna have lots of
draws of those so we can find the mean
lotta mean or aggression line for each
of the participants but we can also
visual we can also plot so these thin
lines are just other regression lines
plotted using some of the posterior
draws and it's we can just essentially
over plot these lines and get a sense
for the uncertainty we have we could
make some sort of like ribbon plot or
something like that but I really like
doing it this way so each one of these
is actually a regression line that is
from the posterior distribution of the
model that is consistent at least to
some extent with the data right I could
just plot a point prediction through
that line but here we actually get to
see this is like I don't know a hundred
different regression lines for each
person but I could get however many
posterior samples I tell stand to give
me yep
yeah my prior here was I don't even know
I would think about it and generally
think about it harder in general yeah
sure yeah the the difference that you'd
find in any given example could be big
could be small basically in terms of the
difference between like what are stan
arm is doing and what like the LME for
package is doing which I think they're
doing like maximum marginal likelihood
or something like that
is a little bit I can let me point you
to a resource instead of hanging above
time so if you you can link to it on the
our stand arm web page in the vignettes
so I'll put this link in the thing but
I'll show you that one of them is about
these there's a section on like a
comparison with the LM you for package
and it talks about essentially that
you're going to get doing it the non
basing way you're going to get under
estimates of like the hierarchical
variance components basically is it
you're gonna underestimate your
uncertainty how much that matters to you
is kind of specific to there but I'll
put that link there but it's a good
question I think one of the the main
benefits I would say is actually going
what you could do going further than
this which is getting the predictive
distributions for the observables right
like in some sense who cares about the
parameters they're just they're not real
we just made them up right they're there
to hopefully capture some useful
structure of the problem but eventually
we want to translate them into some
statement about
the world are about the thing that we
care of and to do that we make
predictions for the outcome variable and
so the real power of the Bayesian
approach there is that you you get a
full posterior predictive distribution
and then you can do all this nice
coherent decision theory and and all of
that but there are benefits in the
estimation to the disadvantages this is
slower than running LME for so I would
say we're giving you a better more full
answer but you're sacrificing some speed
certainly that's a good question yes
different so what I thought you were
going to say which maybe you also mean
is that you can get like for example or
you can get an LM e for when it does
this print output you can get like 1 or
minus 1 here or like 0 here for example
which we can avoid in this context
because the priors help with this so you
get like pathological situations that
don't work from the maximum marginal
likelihood perspective but do in the
Bayesian perspective if you just mean
that you get like one of the part you
mean like one of the parameters for the
participants or something yeah so in
theory you should be able to if you had
some prior information to suggest that
then you could encode that and that
would help in that situation if you have
no reason ahead of time to think that
that's true it's questionable whether or
not you should put that in the model but
if you do right if you don't believe the
result that you're getting it probably
means you had some information that
wasn't being included in the model right
and so in that case yeah it probably
makes sense that you do have some prior
information that wasn't put in the model
that if you did would be closer to what
you we're thinking so yeah I think does
that make sense it's okay but is it okay
I could talk to me after and I'll try to
give a better answer another question
you raise your raising your hand sorry
yeah
the dashed line should be the same in
each of the plots correct I think most
of the solid lines not as steep yeah
that yes in not oh yeah I could see that
so that's possible and this put it's
really gonna depend on the example it's
possible that there's a lot of pooling
being done in this example I'm not sure
but that is one thing to look at in a
picture like this right it's like what
is tending to happen to how are these
other lines getting pulled so there's a
plot in the paper I think it's in the
paper that also plots on here
essentially it shows you what shows you
another line here that's like a degree
of pooling that's going on I'm not sure
if we put that in the paper or not but
yes I think I see what you mean here the
dashed lines look pretty steep yeah I
don't know it's probably it's something
going on with the data with the priors
with the I'm not sure that these the
priors had negative values for the
parameters but not for the outcome
yes yeah yes that's a good point yes
well that's certainly what's encoded by
yes so there's right so there's um
there's a global intercept term here
also that's shifting everything by a
certain amount if that's what you're
saying but yeah the degree to which the
slope differs between the population
estimate and the individual participants
is going to be sensitive to the
particular data set to the strength of
the priors to things like that which we
didn't like go super into detail about
what we were using in this example but
if we did yeah I would say we could
investigate what impact different prior
distributions would have on the amount
of shrinkage that's going on here the
amount of pulling the slopes at
different direction from the population
slope you could look at let's you could
take this data set and try to add
information to it like make the noise
lower and see if that changes it or if
you added more noise to the raw data
then right there'd be less and unique
information pulling it in different
directions for the individual
participants so there's like a lot of
stuff that's going to depend on this
individual data set but yeah most the
idea mostly is like in some cases it it
won't matter like all the participants
might look pretty similar and in other
cases the data will suggest that they
look really different but we probably
want to know that right which is why I
tend to and this is something that
Richard McElrath also says who wrote the
really good statistical rethinking book
is that I tend to think by default about
fitting models like this and then
finding out that there's not much
variation across participant then
assuming there isn't ahead of time and
starting with like a regular GLM so kind
of there were you know I realized that I
fit a GL m and then GL m with
these group level parameters second but
in some sense it kind of makes sense to
just start with this model because it
seems like a more reasonable assumption
that there is going to be variation than
there isn't but but an advantage to
fitting the simpler model first is that
you can always check like okay what am i
learning by adding this component into
the model by adding these so one thing I
don't have not gonna have the time to do
here but we could look now and in the
code that I'll share the last section is
going over the lu package that I
mentioned we could look I'll run it
quickly but we can look at which model
is like expected to have better
out-of-sample predictive performance
right and in this case it is the
multi-level model which is some and
again I don't have much time to go into
this but it's in the code and I'm gonna
link to the vignettes on it but you know
we want to ask the question was it worth
it to add all this extra structure to
the model right and in this case the
structure is not incredibly complicated
but you can imagine that we did some
other we could have a lot more bearing
parameters we could have a nonlinear
model we could have get at all so we
could add time varying effects we could
have smooth terms or whatever we could
add a lot of complicated structure to
the model and then you want some way of
saying was it worth it to add all this
structure and so one way to say that is
well do I improve the expected
predictive performance of my model and
that's what the liu package is designed
for and so I'll share this code here and
you can see it's quite simple to use it
you just put the line Lu here but it'll
give you essentially different estimates
of like the difference in future
predictive performance for these models
now that assumes that the underlying
data generating process is not going to
like suddenly change when you go into
the future but so that's what the next
step might be to say was it worth adding
this next level of structure to the
model right if this model had a ton of
predictors the next step may be like can
we use the prodigy find a subset that
does
almost each they're for all sorts of
different purposes I couldn't I'm not
even familiar with most of them in fact
no I'm who's here and I were having a
conversation the other day about how it
would be nice to have a little more
suggestions and recommendations for good
unit testing procedures for packages
based off of Stan and so there's this
growing kind of extension of the
ecosystem that is where just any user
can now develop a stand pat that is
based or an R package that's based on
Stan and again you can use the AR Stan
tools package you could get here by
clicking on our stand tools in my slide
or the Stan website slash name of our
package will bring you right to the
website for any of the our packages but
if you do want to create your own
packages interfacing with Stan we have
kind of a vignette here that'll go
through how do you use our stand tools
to set up that package and put your
stand program in there and get it all to
work nicely and pre-compile so that when
somebody wants to run a model they don't
have to wait for the stand program to to
compile but again we're actually going
to have our stand tools 2.0 soon that'll
slightly change some of these things but
we think that'll make it even easier ok
so what does it mean to have our package
that's based on Stan with precompiled
models so the primary example of that is
our Stan arm which stands arm is applied
regression modeling and so again I
encourage you I'm going to use some of
these websites as part of this talk
because we're trying to actually make
these useful this was built with
packaged down so thank you badly or
somebody you yeah but so what does it
look like to
I don't know fit a model with the arstan
arm package it looks a lot like I'm
gonna show you another example here but
it looks alright that's like the same
formula that you could put to the GLM
function with a binomial blank right
except these things are different right
but otherwise if you've ever used the
regular GLM function you could put for a
binomial regression right a formula like
that a data frame everything's exactly
the same as it would be if you use GLM
there are just these optional lines here
that we may talk about but they're
actually optional we have some default
settings for that where you can specify
prior distributions all right but the
point of the package in particular our
stand arm is to make transitioning from
using the standard our modeling tools to
getting posterior distributions for
those same models as easy as possible
basically right so you don't need to
learn any new syntax you might need to
learn new concepts if you're trying to
get into Bayesian statistics right the
role of prior distributions how do we
work with posterior distributions and
posterior predictive distributions but
you don't need to learn any new syntax
at least to fit the same models that
you're already fitting with GLM but also
with the mixed effects models the GLM ER
models and all sorts of other of other
ones and in fact these are the lists of
modeling functions in our stand arm at
the moment I don't know if you can see
but basically for a lot of different
standard ones so there's a beta reg
function and are for the beta regression
and you can just put a stand prefix in
front of it for wealth or this is this
happens to there's a big LM function in
R which is like a memory efficient
linear model function you could put a
stand in front of it I don't know if
there's a closure
func
but anyway you can do that there's the
gam for package which fits like smooth
generalized additive models you can
stick a stamp a stand prefix in front of
it
right GLM these are the ones from the
LME for package like the linear mixed
effects models and generalized linear
mixed effects models I'm noticing now
that I need to update this because we
also have the nonlinear models now from
the LME for package like the Stan
oh no it's here sorry the Stan and Elmer
and then a couple things that I'm not
sure have analog oh here's polar for
ordinal models and then we have some
multivariate generalized linear models
and some joint
I guess survival models are longitudinal
on time to event models which I'm not
sure actually have a an analog in the
standard our package world I'm not sure
about that but most cases you take the
function that you're already using put a
stand underscore in front and your 3/4
of the way on your way to getting an
actual getting a posterior distribution
for that so let me show you what that
looks like in action I'm grabbing a data
set from a paper that I was going to say
that I wrote I really didn't write any
of this Chelsey with Chelsey mutant Z 2
or of X from Penn State they did almost
all of this and I chimed in and said oh
that's really good that's really good
but it's a tutorial so they're in the
psychology department at Penn State and
it's a tutorial on using our Stan armed
and shiny Stan in psychology but for now
I'm just grabbing the data set that they
use so I can fit our Stan our model and
the variables of interest in that data
set are and I guess these are official
terms in certain fields of psychology
but they're interesting for to me
valence and arousal so those have
particular definitions here
surveillances levels of pleasant
feelings and arousal is
of activation whatever the hymns exactly
but these are self-reported scores all
right but the point here is not to say
is this a good experiment or not but to
show you how would you what would you do
in our stent arm if you wanted to fit a
model predicting levels of balance from
levels of self-reported levels of
arousal and and then if you wanted to
allow that to vary by participant in the
study right to make separate estimates
for the participant and then how to use
some of the other our packages to look
at the results and again so you can you
can take a look at like the full thing
that this is from in this paper here
that that's linked to here and though
there's like code and data are here but
it's a good example for our stand arm
because the models don't take long to
fit and so I'm going to dive into the
dangerous world of live coding here
should I make this bigger how's that can
people see okay you don't have to worry
about this stuff right here but
basically it's a bunch of like regular
our code that I'm not going to worry
about here this is just a ggplot of the
data
ya know it's either a good or bad
advertisement of our studio today we're
going to find out hopefully good I like
our studio so anyway this is a scatter
plot for each of the 20 participants in
the study or a subset of 20 and maybe
this is a subset of a larger study where
you have the self-reported arousal
levels on scales from one to a hundred
and same with the valence on the y-axis
here so these are like raw data points
like self-reported points by participant
we can see that it's possible that
there's different stuff going on here
for sorry for different participants but
we're gonna focus on pretty simple
models here just for today but so if you
just wanted to do like the most basic
thing and say let's just fit a linear a
simple linear regression model here well
you could use the LM function and R or
you could just use GL m which defaults
to family is Gaussian which is just a
linear regression model so to fit that
in our stand arm we actually could I
could stop here and now it's like
exactly the same code as GL m and this
will actually run but I want to show you
some of these extra options here it's
running in parallel here and for a
simple model like this it takes longer
to like spawn the processes than to
actually run the the models but so you
can specify how many cores to use I
guess it was using one how many courses
you so you can run these models in
parallel because we're running many
Markov chains at the same time to do
sampling from the posterior distribution
well I want to show you first is in our
stand arm know so there's GPU
functionality that is coming to stand
let's see do you remember the latest
when that
coming out I don't know it might it
might be already right but not in our
stand arm yet at least what the Jeep
what the GPU will let you do will do
like you know like cholesky
factorization the matrices like big
things like that and use GPUs for that
but that is not implemented in our sin
arm yet although I assume we probably
will allow for that at some point but
yeah there's GPU functionality coming to
stand right now what this will do is
just send a different Markov chain to
each processor each CP CPU processor
yeah but I wanted to show this one
argument here which doesn't exist in
regular GL m and couldn't really exist
in regular GL m which I see now is
exactly in the wrong spot on the screen
okay which says prior PD equals true
prior PD here stands for the prior
predictive distribution so this we have
default prior distributions going on on
here I'm not going to get too much into
that because we could spend I don't know
when I do stand classes for Jared we
spend tons of time talking about prior
distributions I want to go down down
that role but there are prior
distributions being used here and you
can specify your own which we recommend
doing if you and so what what setting
this argument will do is it will draw
from the prior distribution for you and
then if you make predictions afterwards
that's equivalent to predicting from the
prior predictive distribution as and
what is what am I saying before I learn
anything from the data right so
essentially what's going to happen here
is it's going to like run the model but
it's not going to condition on the
valence variable and the estimates that
we get out at the end are going to
summarize the prior distribution and
then we could make predictions from the
model and look at what is what are our
priors implying that the distribution
for the outcome is right and this is a
good thing to do before
you start fitting models and going down
that ranch because it's a way of saying
are ma am I making assumptions that are
consistent with my prior knowledge about
the situation right and if sometimes
it's hard to know that by saying what's
my prior distribution in this case it's
relatively easy because we have like one
predictor here and it's a linear model
but in other cases like thinking about
what the prior distribution on one
particular coefficient and a big
complicated model isn't necessarily
going to tell you if the data generating
process that's implied by these choices
of priors is realistic for the outcome
variable of interest all right and to do
that you need to just the same way that
after we fit a model we can make
predictions which are basically
summarizing what the models saying about
the outcome variable after we learn from
the data we can do it ahead of time and
saying what are our assumptions
basically ahead of time and are they
reasonable given what we already know
and so to do that so if I did that and
then I plotted and then I plot them
hmm let's make a histogram and step
so our stand arm has this plot method
that is using the base plot package that
I mentioned behind the scenes you can
directly get the output yourself and use
the baseball package yourself and
there's some code later in this file
that does that but the our stand arm
plot method and this is the same with a
bunch of other our packages that depend
on Stan have methods that there it's
doing the work for you and make it and
then calling that base plot package but
you can go in yourself and use base pot
also and so these may or may not be
reasonable at all priors and that's not
really what I'm trying to think about
right now but these are are the implied
default priors that are going on in this
particular case so this is an example if
you can look at what assumptions you're
making ahead of time by specifying this
prior PD argument instead of just
starting to fit models without saying
what am I actually what assumptions of
my making well the assumptions that I'm
making are these are reasonable prior
values for these parameters and also
that if I made predictions based on this
that it would be a reasonable summary of
my current state of knowledge about the
outcome before using this new data that
I have about it okay there's a if you
look more at the base plot package
there's some links to a paper that the
package is related to that goes into a
lot more of this and I'll add the link
to but then so then if we actually fit
the model here with prior Peete without
the prior PD argument and we can look
all right does this make sense and this
is a somewhat similar to regular output
from our but a little bit different for
the top we get some summary info
information number of predictors is two
because technically there's an intercept
also and that's being counted and then
we report these weird weird summary
statistics here right so well first of
all there's no p-values there's no T
statistic there's these statistics or
whatever they use
and but there's not even means or
standard deviations so by default what
we've chosen to report here are
posterior medians and a stand a version
of the standard deviation based on the
median absolute deviation and basically
the reason is is that these are more
robust to distribute posterior
distributions with for example fat tails
or other things or god forbid you had a
CO she like distribution that didn't
even have a mean or something like that
in other words it's always valid to
report these regardless about what's
going on with like higher moments of the
posterior distribution but so by default
we're reporting things that are always
valid to report what you can get all the
oops but the summary function will go
into a lot more detail here and actually
give you posterior means standard
deviations quantiles MCMC diagnostics
all that stuff all that stuff here and
so the nice thing though is that because
we're in our this yeah so this fitted
model object which we call a stand reg
object has all these methods associated
with it and so all the standard ones
like Co F and all these other things are
going to work for this they're going to
give you some they're going to give you
they're going to give you point
estimates that are based on these
posterior distributions but they'll work
but we recommend actually going and
using these full posterior distributions
so if I I could plot will look at the
posterior distributions of the
coefficients
so these are now the posterior
distributions for the intercept for the
coefficient on the arousal variable and
for the residual standard deviation and
the idea here is that yeah you could
pick the mean or the median or some
point estimate and plug it in to
whatever you're doing next but ideally
you'll actually take this full
distribution which summarizes your
uncertainty and do whatever you're doing
next for each value in this distribution
and propagate that uncertainty forward
so if you wanted to compute some let's
see like if you wanted to make a
prediction then instead of plugging in
like summaries of these distributions
and using those to make the predictions
you'd actually make a prediction for
each value of the posterior distribution
and you get a whole distribution of the
predictions right instead of a point
prediction and a standard error or
something like that
for example here
let's do ass
so this function in our stein arm which
is called pee-pee check for posterior
predictive check is another function
that's calling this Bayes plot package
under the hood so you can call base plot
yourself and do a little processing but
our center arm will figure out okay what
does it need to do with this particular
model object to make the right plot and
so what this is doing is it's taking its
making a hundred predictions these are
in sample predictions we could plot
out-of-sample predictions also but then
I need to pass like a new data frame for
those but it's it's making a hundred
predictions right but it's making 100
predictions of the full data set Y so
the size of this data set is 272
observations so it's making its
predicting 272 observations a hundred
times does that make sense I have two
hundred and seventy two full predicted
data sets but that means that like sorry
I have one hundred full data sets each
of size 200 and whatever actually in
fact why don't I
is that clear to everyone no let me let
me make it even clearer so what it's
doing under the hood is calling this
nice function called posterior predict
this is like the predict function in R
except it's all weight so here let's see
I'm gonna call it Y rep so
unfortunately this argument name and
this argument name are different for
weird historical reasons but okay so
this line of code here is drawing the
datasets that are going to be used by
this function to make the plot so I'm
showing you kind of what's going on
internally so this Y rip object is going
to have two hundred and whatever columns
the number of data points that I have in
my original model and a hundred rows and
so I could even because our studio is
cool I could even click on this yeah so
the first row here is a prediction for
each of the two hundred and whatever
values in the data set using the first
sample from the posterior distribution
so like the first saved iteration of the
Markov chain which is going to have a
unique value of alpha beta and Sigma
right and the second row is using the
next draw from the posterior
distribution pick predict a whole data
set right and so if you looked at the
columns then what they'd be telling you
is like for the first data point in the
data set that I have here's a
distribution of predictions for it now
these are in sample but that posterior
predict function accepts a new data
argument just like the predict function
in R so you could get out of sample
prediction stew all right I don't
remember I think these are sequential
there was a there's originally R Stan
was like permuting draws for you but
actually we now think that's a really
bad idea so we're here at that I think I
think these should these the ones that
were due is in our sin are more
sequential it shouldn't matter yeah no
but like the posterior draws like if you
call as extract on a stand fed object it
has this weird / muted argument anyway
it shouldn't we good job predicting the
outcome variable for example anyway I
feel like I've talked for a while are
there other questions I'm happy to
answer other questions about this stuff
or Bayesian statistics yeah it's a good
question
there can be convergence issues so what
our Stan arm will do so for the most
part that types of models that you're
fitting with are Stan arm package are
pretty robust in in the sense that
they're like there's a lot more
complicated stuff you could do writing
your own models in the Stan language
than just the models that have been like
pre-written and our Stan arm so these
have fewer convergence issues you will
get lots of warnings if something goes
wrong and recommendations of what to
look at but you don't get as much of
that with our Stan arm not nearly as
much as you would with like running
writing your own Stan programs partially
because and it's just easy to make
mistakes when you're writing Stan
program and these are already written
but also just because like we're using
lots of tricks and Reaper ammeter is a
shion's and all sorts of other stuff
behind the scenes in our sent arm to try
to make the models as amenable as
possible to the sampling that Stan uses
but you'll get warnings about our hat
Diagnostics and these things called
divergences if you want to learn more
you can about that you could come to the
summer class I'll probably do it Jared
but so there are fewer convergence
problems with these models than with
like general Stan models but they still
exist and it can have to do with your
data set in particular and which priors
you're using if you use it like we offer
a prior called like the horseshoe prior
and hierarchical shrinkage priors and
some of these are trickier to sample
from and so you might get warnings and
there's a lot of stuff that we have
written so I recommend
for example so again all of these are
linked so for example the base plot
package website that you can go to from
here has been yet all about like if you
get those convergence warnings sorry
so this is where it'll take you if you
click on the link to base plots base
plot and there's a visual MCMC
Diagnostics vignette that's basically
like a good resource for if you get
those warnings when running a model like
this you can go there it'll tell you how
to make pictures of them and understand
what the different Diagnostics are
telling you and if for example maybe you
need to fit a different you know rewrite
your model or unfortunately with our
stand arm if the tips and tricks don't
get your model to converge you can't
just go in there and tweak some part of
the stand code underlying the model you
can tweak all sorts of settings that we
anticipated right and allow you you can
change things about the MCMC sampling or
and all that stuff but you can't change
the actual stand code in the our stand
arm program but the BRMS package which I
didn't show but is another package that
it's developed mostly about Paul Berkner
who's not part of the standing that will
actually write a stand program for you
on the fly and could just give you a
program for you to edit yourself if you
want it to make some like let's say you
ask a question on the stand users list
and they say oh you should change your
model like this to avoid convergence
problems then if you actually need to
edit the stand code you couldn't do that
in our stand arm but you could for BRMS
ya know yeah that's a good point I guess
what I meant more was like maybe the
model that you're fitting maybe we say
oh you should fit a slightly different
model but our San arm doesn't have that
model then you couldn't just slightly
tweak the code in our stand arm to give
you that model well you could in the
source code but then you'd have to like
rebuild the package and all that stuff
or maybe submit a pull request to us
there's nothing like that but but yeah
so so you can't change the underlying
code of the our centaur models but you
shouldn't have if you know you're
fitting the model you want to be fitting
and it's not converging and you're using
our San arm there's probably not like a
better way to write the same model and
stand but there might be other ways to
write similar models that are more
likely to converge or something like
that yeah yeah that our Stan arm will do
for you yeah automatically actually ya
know it's it's just using it's by
default using the non centered
parameterization we can get into that
not currently in our stand arm but
that's mostly for those of you don't
know we're just that there's different
ways to write the same statistical model
some of them are more easily sampled
from using MCMC than others and we chose
a certain way to tend to write the
models in our set arm that tends to work
most often and seems to work pretty well
even when some other parameters ations
are better and the other way is not true
the converse is not true but yeah so we
don't give you too much control over the
parameterizations will be try to write
the ones that work best in the majority
of situations of course if you write
your own stand programs you can use
whatever parameterization you want but
yeah that's a good question but oh my
last thing I'll say is that if you want
to use any of this stuff and you have
questions we really do like answering
questions this is the Stan forums please
ask questions about any of this stuff no
question is too
you know if you're a beginner that's
fine it's not just for like super
advanced technical questions we like
questions from beginners to and then
check out like all the websites like
each one of these all the documentation
is online all the vignettes are online
we have like ten vignettes for our stein
arm that just talk about all the
different kinds of models you can fit
and workflow and let us to know if you
use it and have questions or if you want
to contribute to the stand
ecosystem in our now is a good time for
that and then hopefully we'll have a
several day intensive stand course this
summer through Jared which will cover
writing your own stand programs but also
all of these tools for like
visualization and model comparison and
all that other stuff and then I'll stick
around for a bit afterwards if you want
to talk more after thanks
[Applause]